new at six casinos are essentially
enormous Banks billions of dollars flow
through whether you win or lose and just
like Banks casinos are now connected to
the internet so that means they're
vulnerable to cyber attacks so how is
this industry protecting itself and
Staffing up John langler takes a closer
look
so if you go in and click on this link
it should download the file for you
welcome to a playing field well I'm
basically giving NCL all of Saturday
just without the field without the ball
the players have computers instead of
equipment code instead of plays it's
part of the national cyber League played
by grad students at UNLV the bad guys
keep getting better we need talent Dr
Dan Manson teaches cyber security at
UNLV NCL is a way to challenge his own
students against others around the
country to test their skills and meet
the Relentless demand we have 500 000
professionals Nationwide but we need
close to a million and Las Vegas is no
exception we certainly have a big Target
lots of them the entire Las Vegas strip
for example cyber security experts say
the resort industry has been slow to
wake up to the online threat locally
regionally
um cyber security was not a big deal for
a while Greg Moody is director of unlv's
cyber security program we spoke with him
in 8 the casinos will back this up when
I moved here in 2011 I was like oh let
me reach out I'll ask about like how's
your cyber security they're like we
don't do anything you can't operate uh
in a box any longer Jim Barbie handles
it for the Nevada Gaming Control Board
it's working on new regulations now for
casinos to follow specifically for cyber
security maybe years ago there might
have been a notion that gaming
operations were disconnected and I don't
think that's the case and it's not been
the case for quite some time more gaming
is online now it's Nationwide it makes
major operations more vulnerable indeed
several major attacks have already
happened you're using the internet you
are networked gaming controls new
regulations would require casinos to
evaluate their own cyber security risks
top to bottom however that risk
assessment isn't designed to be public
Regulators may never see them unless
something bad happens the hashes have
already been pre-computed and uploaded
to a database which is why this program
at UNLV is so important the school is
working with major resorts create a
roster of talent which can grow here and
stay here you have to develop the talent
for them to want you let the games begin
John langler 8 News Now